these farmers in lebanon are harvesting
lettuce meant for households in saudi
arabia
but after the saudi government imposed
the ban on lebanese produce
they fear the agricultural sector will
face a disaster
saudi officials say the shipments are
being used to smuggle drugs
it's an arbitrary decision so we ask the
saudis to reverse the ban
we're not all drug dealers and smugglers
you can't punish everyone
lebanon exports four hundred thousand
tons of agricultural produce every year
one-fourth to saudi arabia and the wider
gulf region
it's millions of dollars for a country
facing a deep economic
and financial crisis manor men and
we don't export pomegranates
investigations show the truck came from
syria
but yes you can argue the lebanese
government is not doing its job there
are no scanners at the borders with
syria or at the ports
corruption in governance has plagued
this country for years
there is little control along its
borders whether with neighboring syria
or at ports where smuggling is rampant
and evasion of custom tax costs the
state
billions of dollars in revenues
lebanon has a long history of drug
cultivation and trafficking
the bika valley is a source of opium and
hashish
production factories producing captagon
pills
have been discovered as well western
drug agencies say
the amphetamine is also widely
manufactured in syria
the discovery of 5.3 million captagon
pills in saudi arabia
was the latest drug bust coming from
lebanon the timing of the ban
has raised the question if politics is
at play
this disengagement strategy that saudi
uh
arabia as well as the broader gulf has
adopted vis-a-vis lebanon
is slowly turning into more of an
engagement but a negative engagement
strategy in that case to really up the
pressure on the lebanese government
saudi arabia whose influence in lebanon
has waned in recent years
is angered by what many see is the
iranian-backed hezbollah's control
and influence in the country lebanon's
leaders
ordered the security services to crack
down on drug smuggling and those behind
it
decisions are not in the hands of the
lebanese government but in the hands of
hezbollah the smuggling routes are under
its control
so is the airport and the ports there is
no state
in lebanon there is a lot of uncertainty
saudi arabia wants guarantees that what
it calls
systematic smuggling operations and few
here believe
it will be easy to control the drug
trade senator al jazeera beirut